Spencer Heidi thank you for doing this
with us first of all how you guys doing
right now about is so much fun I I've
seen your Instagram stories I see that
you still are playing reputation they're
still doing the morning coffee situation
we're still feeding the hummingbirds
what is a typical day like or have your
days really changed they have changed
more to our life in Santa Barbara so
it's our life that we had for so many
years but then we moved to LA but every
time when a blessing to stay here and be
here there's just been so busy so it's
been nice to be home again are you in
touch with the family that are you guys
speaking to like your parents talking to
Stephanie right now I am the six feet is
like energetically to me also I have no
contact
focusing on I got a great audio book
called own your energy so that's been my
life side has been focusing on my like
right now I actually have a aura divider
between us I didn't get to that chapter
I'm at the chapter right now no I
haven't been talking to anyone but Heidi
gunner and hummingbirds and obviously
God more praying than ever
oh hey how is gunner handling this is he
like understanding what's going on or is
he just kind of extra happy to have both
of his parents around all the time
I think he was getting way over the
hills filming and I think he's so happy
and that's the positive out of all this
the world is a very scary sad place
right now but if I'm not gonna resonate
that frequency so you can save your BMS
how are the Pratt daddy crystals help
you guys stay positive and keep up with
a good energy are they helping oh gosh I
got to bring all the ones from the
office home and now Heidi's like you
have to sell those like you you're
looking at it this is our living room
and we're packaging everything and it's
been really nice because I feel like
before gunner I could focus more on like
myself and prayer time and energy and
then this has been a good read browning
and recruit they might be able to
meditate and feel the frame or focus on
like crystal energy and staging so it's
been nice to be able to refocus on the
crystals and like our love of them
sometimes we're so busy and your
packaging I'm shipping them and now I
could look at each one and love it
already just kept this one I keep
keeping them all naturally does it bring
you like calmness it brings us et
superstardom energy speaking of
superstardom can we interrupt this
interview with how users really talk
about Taylor Swift for a few minutes
because if you don't already know
she is funding the local Nashville a
record store take all the employees as
Taylor and she's helping like with their
health care for three months I mean this
woman can we just take a minute to just
remember we do have to talk about the
hills because I know you guys were
filming season two when this all started
happening so where were you at in
production when things sort of shut down
or are you guys even still filming in
quarantine right now hashtag I don't
know they said no spoilers but I'm not I
can't you ask me question I'll be honest
uh yes they have figured out how to
continue filming while in quarantine so
it's it is what it is but before the
quarantine the hills became the best
show ever like it got so good I was
oh my gosh so it's kind of frustrating
because I'm concerned you know everyone
hopefully everyone still I think maybe
once we all get out of this arrow so
turn up to be I outfit everyone's
emotions will keep going but yeah I was
really good and it's only the beginning
there's wrong answers that I never saw
coming out of left field so I love
reality shows I love romance are you
guys playing matchmaker for anyone I
don't think we have to I think
everyone's playing matchmaker for
themselves I think there's a lot of
people on the rebound - from former
relationships that might be looking for
new relationships I think there's a lot
of drama going on in people's marriages
and wives - that will be interesting to
play out so there's a lot one of the
positives that's helped the show with
the quarantine is I just look on the
Daily Mail sorry team didn't have this
scoop yet mate I'm sorry but they had a
they had a photo in a video of Brody
Jenner a Hills cast member quarantine 8
with a super-famous
20 year old tic-tock star Daisy so I'm
really hoping that Brody brings Daisy on
the show because that will help Heidi
stick talk to count as Heidi's also so
that is exciting and I think those two
look like a perfect match
well I was gonna ask you is there any
legitimacy to this relationship have you
talked to Brody is this a real thing I
was texting with him and told him that
we needed to get his tik-tok account and
get it verified so he seemed like that
was important which if it wasn't a
serious relationship he probably what do
you care about having a verified tik-tok
so I took that as oh it's serious
how did he meet her um I know I didn't
ask that I was more concerned about
making sure he got his tick-tock game
going so that was my priority and I mean
Heidi your tik toks are some of my
favorites to watch so what do you love
most about chick talk and is there a
chance that we're gonna get a
collaboration between you and Miss tasty
I would love to do a cheap talk with
Miss Daisy she's very inspiring and
she's an OG so um yeah she seems great
but I have family someone that we really
want to find love is Audrina yeah my you
find love this season I don't know we'll
see we'll see I don't know quarantines
changed a lot that's what ya got a lot
of romance going on but if you didn't
get quarantine with who you were
romancing with and the a new person got
quarantine of your romance so that is
what's the me interesting with the
quarantine because kind of like who you
ended up getting caught evening with to
be a new love it it's Brody quarantine
II with Daisy is not a thing no spoiler
alert I don't know they said I don't
know literally attached no spoilers yes
yes okay a spoiler but Kristin Cavallari
exclusively told Ichi that she's gonna
be making a cameo in season two is that
still happening with all of this the
shelter in place
hashtag alone together once that is
lifted definitely but I'm more concerned
about Jay Cutler coming with
because anyone has seen Gary Cavallari a
Cutler is the biggest breakout reality
TV star I'm sorry to say he's a better
reality TV star they quarterback
oh I did it I sorry Jay but I would love
to come with Christine LA so we can all
go drinking I hate to break it to you
but Kristen told me Jay will not be on
the hills Heidi it was so fun to see you
on very Cavallari so what will be
different when she appears on the hills
do you think it will be really different
because that's the first time her Trina
and I have hung out together in a while
it was her home turf and her life I'm
you're seeing what's going on her store
and with her friends and in Nashville
and here she's gonna be with a group of
people and a lot of things have changed
and I know that she and Brody are
friends and they've kept in touch so
that will be you know it's a whole
different dynamic it's not just like the
two of us and for life it's a whole cast
you can't really contain that kind of
situation so we'll see Wow how are you
guys filming right now so are you like
video chatting with cast number that
that could I don't want to give other
networks any ideas our lives and
snapchat Instagram so I would think you
know it's just more there's a lot no
crew members though our inside shelter
hashtag alone together
[Music]